[Musique]
à la moindre erreur
le patient meurt
c'est la phrase que j'ai le plus entendu
dans vos pauses d'assistante ne comptiez
en assurances et fonds de pension elle
venait tous les jours et elle nous
disait on n'avait pas droit à l'erreur
inlassablement c'était une phrase qui
étaient répétées aussi incongru que cela
puisse paraître cette phrase me suit et
me hante encore aujourd'hui je suis et
si kodjo je suis passé des fonds de
pension aux chiffons il ya quelques
années des gratte ciel d'amérique du
nord
orru rouge de nos villes de nos villages
d'un environnement chiffrer car et un
manque de créativité et de artistique
on a l'impression beaucoup plus léger le
patient mourut dans mes bras un jour je
venais d'enregistrer mon premier dossier
de clients il fallait l'enregistrer dans
notre base de données
j'avais bien tout fait en tout cas
j'étais sûr d'avoir tout fait tout bien
fait mais j'ai manqué une petite case il
fallait juste indiqué que le
bénéficiaire de l'assurance vie de
monsieur était irrévocable
une petite case à cocher
vous savez supposons que monsieur koffi
viennent chez nous et prennent une
assurance vie il désigne son épouse
comme bénéficiaire et vocable surtout
pour de jeunes mariés on pense que tout
sera toujours parfait monsieur koffi ne
pourra jamais changer de bénéficiaire
tenté aussi longtemps que madame le
signe on accepte mais il fallait que
cette petite case soit cochet continuant
et supposons que l'erreur n'est pas été
découverte quelques années plus tard
monsieur et madame divorce
monsieur se remarie et bien entendu il
faudrait que sa nouvelle épouse soit
bénéficiaire par la première il revient
vers nous et sans cette petite case
cochée nous n'aurions jamais exiger la
signature de la première épouse de
madame de monsieur koffi donc nous
aurions payé et donc vous imaginez quel
tort cela aurait pu causer à la première
épouse
et comment en mettez du coup
l'entreprise sujette à des poursuites
et forcément à une condamnation à payer
des milliers si ce n'est des millions de
dollars tout cela à cause d'une petite
case vous devez sans doute être perdu je
vous parle d'assurance de fonds de
pension et je vous parle d'un patient
qui meurt comment sommes nous passés
d'un hôpital où on soigne à ce
gratte-ciel de l'avenue rené lévesque en
plein centre ville de montréal
tout simplement avec ma directrice elle
était infirmière dans une vue passer en
chine avant de devenir courtier en
assurances et fonds de pension en
immigrants au canada
de cette vie elle a gardé je n'ai pas le
droit à l'erreur et personne aucun où
aucune de ses collaboratrices ou
collaborateurs n'avaient droit à
l'erreur ce qu'on pouvait considérer
comme petite erreur elle considérait
qu'il n'y avait pas on n'avait pas le
droit à l'erreur car chaque erreur
pouvait thuy le patient une erreur pour
elle était tout simplement la mauvaise
orthographe y d'un an une virgule de
trop ou en moins dans le dossier un
fonds de pension qu'on n'a pas bien
choisi parce que c'est parce que le
client a voulu
la petite case à cocher
j'ai donc passé quelques années avec
elle et puis survint dans ma propre vie
un événement qui m'oblige à revenir au
pays après plus de deux décennies en
occident on met sa vie dans les cartons
avec beaucoup d'appréhension on se dit
mon dieu le pays que j'ai laissé depuis
qu'est ce que ça va être
je suis rentré et il ya eu deux
premières semaines
magnifique le retour pays on se
reconnecte avec la nourriture avec les
parents avec les amis qu'on a laissée
derrière
à ce moment là même la poussière vous
paraît tellement agréable tout est
parfait et après s'en est suivi des
chocs tous les jours partout tout le
temps des chocs en allant changer faire
une carte d'identité
l'agent a juste rajouté une lettre en
plus sur mon nom j'ai changé de
patronyme le choc en demandant un
menuisier de m'installer une planche
pour mes livres il l'a transformé
l'étagère en toboggan
la couturière elle et s'est dit bon elle
pourrait avoir dix centimètres en moins
sur les jambes ce serait pas mal
j'étais en choque tout le temps et je me
rendais compte que revenir chez moi
était beaucoup plus dures calais en
occident le choc du retour était
beaucoup plus grand que le choc
thermique subi en allant au canada en
plein hiver je vous raconte pas les -30
et je me demandais mais pourquoi malgré
tout cela parce que passionné d'art et
d'artisanat
j'ai décidé de plonger dans ce monde là
dans cet univers et d'y consacrer ma vie
on a donc commencé par un atelier dans
le textile ont fait des sacs de jolis
sacs en tout cas c'était l'objectif et
vous avez des artisanes qui or mais
madame ça peut aller mais c'est pas très
grave hein c'est juste un peu courbé et
les jours passent et je me disais mon
dieu qu'est-ce qu'elle deviendrait dans
cet atelier ma directrice du canada vous
imaginez le nombre de patients qui
meurent tous les jours
est ce que j'ai réalisé quand elle
n'arrêtait pas de nous dire le patient
doit rester en vie le patient doit pas
mourir je me suis dit mme qu'est-ce
qu'on passerait au pilote dans l'avion
dans lequel on se retrouverait tous et
qui se permettrait une petite erreur
d'aiguillage au moment de l'atterrissage
quelles erreurs pourriez vous passer au
chirurgien qui opère votre enfant
qu'est-ce que vous accepteriez de
l'entrepreneur qui est en train de faire
les fondations pour les trois étages de
maisons que voulait construire pour
votre famille
accepteriez-vous l'erreur non et dans
mon atelier tous les jours la couture
était exact le fil un peu trop tombant
le perlage dents dessus dessous
tout le monde y allait de fou de son
humeur et je me disais mais je garde
quand même gardé quelque chose de ces
années avec cette directrice là qu'est
ce que je pourrais faire passer j'ai
insisté assisté il ya des moments vous
rêvez vous dites non j'y arriverai
jamais c'est la fin du monde c'est pas
possible je n'arrête pas de répéter
inlassablement la même chose et puis
entre incompréhension parfois des
espoirs une toute petite lueur d'espoir
est apparue mais artisanes ont commencé
à comprendre quelque chose à se dire
mais elle est folle oui
son obsession à garder le patient en vie
c'est vraiment pas normal ce n'est que
de la couture mais l'on commencé à
comprendre une s'en est tenu aux
coutures droite une autre au processus
d'assemblage et sacs et en avait de plus
en plus des moments d'extase
l'atelier je me disais on va y arriver
pourquoi tout simplement parce que je me
sentais obligé de transmettre un tout
petit peu de cette fibre que j'ai
apportée depuis le canada pas seulement
pour que le patient reste en vie mais
pour ma propre survie nous parlons des
défis de demain
nous voulons et parlons d'émergence de
nos pays
on voudrait pas immergées à peu près on
voudrait pas émergé en faisant des
erreurs on voudrait émerger avant
l'heure c'est pas l'heure
après l'heure c'est plus l'heure
s'entendent sur des choses et les
respecte et que chacun dans son corps de
métier fasse exactement ce qu'il doit
faire
ferme pas bien son travail mais très
bien son travail
encore une fois pas que pour le patient
mais surtout et avant tout pour nous
mêmes
ça fait sept ans que je suis rentré au
togo et il ya des jours où on se lève et
en suis dit ça y est je suis au bout de
mes peines et de mes choc
nous sommes partis d'ici hier soir après
une belle répétition et j'ai eu encore
un choc
le petit garçon de 4 ans d'un ami à moi
qui s'appelle oedème est décédé hier
soir
vous savez pourquoi sa maman l'a emmené
à l'hôpital le matin parce qu'il ne se
sentait pas bien et avait fait une crise
d'asthme
le médecin n'a pas jugé nécessaire après
avoir stabilisé la fièvre de 39 et
quelques du petit noah il les a libérés
à 16 heures nous ne parlons pas l'un de
problèmes financiers
parce qu'ils peuvent se permettre de
garder l'enfant et de payer cette
hospitalisation là à 19 heures le petit
noah a fait un pic de fiers de 42 il est
rentré dans le coma il est décédé ce
matin nous sommes allés enterré noah
le patient est mort
en préparant ce texte je ne pensais pas
que j'aurai un témoignage aussi poignant
je ne pensais pas que ce que je disais
tout ce que ma directrice nous apprenait
il ya quelques années aurait encore
aujourd'hui autant d'impact et de
résonance tous autant que nous sommes
nous sommes non seulement des patients
mais nous devons garder le patient
amphis pour le petit nuage envie de vous
exhorter tous à faire parfaitement ce
que vous faites dans cette vie aussi
imparfait que nous puissions être en
tant qu'humain nous avons la possibilité
à chaque fois que nous faisons quelque
chose de très bien le faire van gogh
disait greetings ordonne by the reader
small things brut off to gather merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]